hey everybody welcome to the free code
camp 2018 Top Contributors party in
Dublin yeah before we get started I have
some very quick announcements things
that are coming up very soon that I
think everybody who's interested in free
code camp should know first of all just
like last year when freako camp
participated in hack Tober fest and
hacked Ober Fest is the month of october
it's a big push to get people to
contribute to open source last year free
code camps guide was the number one most
contributed to open source repo as part
of Oktoberfest we're taking a lot of the
existing repositories we've got learned
we've got a curriculum we've got the
free code camp slash free cooking at the
main repository and then we've got the
guide we're working to unify these repos
into a single repository that will make
it easier for everybody to get the local
freako camp running a couple other
announcements since you are watching
this on the YouTube channel
according to like the YouTube analytics
we looked at freako camp is now the
fastest growing programming YouTube
channel yeah
and we're getting about 50,000 new
subscribers a month if you create
compelling videos about programming and
you're interested we would love to help
more people see your intent your videos
so just reach out to us and we can make
that happen but for us we want to put as
many amazing videos on YouTube as we can
we're here in Dublin we're at I've got a
cool sign for it the huckle tree which
is a really cool hipster name I'm gonna
try to talk to as many of you all as
possible and just interview you and
learn more about you so
Hey I'm here with Brianna Swift you have
been involved with freako camp this is
basically the beginning maybe you can
just give us a high-level overview of
your involvement with freako camping and
your transition into being a developer
yeah so I found free code camp while I
was an elementary school music teacher I
was trying to learn how to code I love
kids I love teaching music but I knew it
wasn't a career that I wanted to do
forever
so I was like what can I learn how to do
without having to quit my job and go
back to school because I couldn't afford
to do that and I thought the people that
make the internet are probably the first
ones to put all of that information for
free on the internet and so I did
codecademy mostly JavaScript type stuff
and found my way on to free code camp I
was really involved on Twitter that was
my only community cuz I was really kind
of alone while I was learning and went
through the free code camp challenges
and as soon as I started doing that it
started to get involved more in the chat
room which there was no forum at that
point and started doing some pair
programming and streaming that so free
code camp really not only taught me the
fundamentals that I needed for you know
for development and for software but
also gave me a community in a place to
you know commiserate almost and how hard
it is to learn how to go based on your
videos on YouTube and the skills that
you were able to build up just learning
the code on your own and through
different communities you were able to
eventually get a job can you talk a
little bit about your job and how you
got it yeah yes I work at github which
is not where I thought I would be
working when I started learning to code
I'm a trainer so most of the time I'm
talking to developers about how to use
git and github so regardless of what
language they're programming in
regardless of what type of projects how
big their team is everybody should
probably be using version control and
git is not the simplest thing to wrap
your head around so it's a similar
challenge to these computer science
concepts
like how can we make this simple and
approachable this you know that
transition was weird because going from
elementary school music teacher to
working at github is kind of a jump but
but I think working with those videos
specifically and saying how can we take
these difficult concepts and make them
approachable to anybody is something
that really primed me for working at
github so I think even if somebody's
going through free code camp and if
you're going through free code camp and
you're like I don't know if I
necessarily see myself as a full-time
developer that's okay like there are so
many places for you that are perfect for
you that you might just not know exists
like I didn't know that this job existed
but I love it awesome thanks again why
don't you just tell us a little about
yourself Pete sure sir my name's Pete
and I'm a data scientist based in London
and I write for and help out at the
median publication I've been doing that
since about October last year so almost
a year now and it's it's really fun it's
really interesting to see what articles
we receive and and you know you're
curating them and helping it then you
know the heist and we we like to put up
what is your editorial workflow like
about how frequently will you check in
and find articles that you're interested
in editing and publishing I see so we do
receive a lot of articles it was always
something to work on I check in daily I
actually take my lunch breaks at work as
an opportunity to you know see what
there is and review some of the articles
and if I see one I think I can I can
help you know Adam get to universe but
standard we want then I'll you know I'll
claim that article in the evening I'll
work on it and send it to Abby for you
know final review and publishing so it's
thank you thanks Peter have a seat
Ritchie just give us an overview of some
of the things you do yeah so I mean we
met a couple of years back you know free
cocaine was still in its early days and
stuff so so what I do currently is
basically run meetups I'm a core admin
for free cocaine Johnny's burg there's a
couple of other guys that some came and
went and
someone spilled a butts on my domain
semi-active wouldn't need it what needs
be but I'm generally like you know
organized stuff and hosts the meetups
themselves building we're building an
events platform that'll make it easier
for people in Johannesburg when they're
just using free code camp - it'll remind
them hey there's an event in you know at
the nearby office where you're having
your next event
so I I'm optimistic that that will help
even more people who are already in
Johannesburg who don't realize that
you're having all these in-person events
it will help get them involved as well
[Music]
another aspect of it I mean it's we were
talking about how else myself and
evidence we were talking about how else
we can contribute like is this all we
can do you know is that like how do we
take it to the next level and my
response to that was like that's a very
good question brother what do you think
and so he gave me his peace of mind like
for me I think for now is like we need
to continue doing what we've been doing
because personally I mean for me right
the reason why I believe in this and why
I'm still doing whatever what I'm doing
now is that I see value in this you know
I truly believe like this is one way
that we can and I know it sounds very
like up in the sky but I really like
this is one way of actually tackling
poverty and I see people that are
frustrated in their jobs people that
they just you know they just go to work
just for the heck of it but they don't
enjoy it you know and for me I strongly
believe in their like you have to really
enjoy what you do and I absolutely love
what I'm doing right now and thanks to
free code camp and I think the way just
back to my original point was that how
to take it forward is first of all we
need to keep doing what we're doing
you know don't drop the standard and
obviously think of other ways of how we
can improve it weather is
I don't know like maybe writing articles
if you would say you were doing like you
should star for you hosting meetups
maybe just you know think of other ways
of contributing more or at least getting
other people to feel the same passion
that you have so that they can also
continue in and contribute to the
platform in in different ways
Richie it's been such a pleasure man
thank you so much for flying out here
well David you are a prolific writer
among other things and I think you have
a very interesting background can you
tell the audience a little bit about
yourself and how you got into coding and
writing my code okay first of all Quincy
I'm really grateful to you that you
created free code came because I think
it was really the major helper for me to
switch my careers because as you
mentioned I was working as a lawyer I
have a law degree and then I was working
as a lawyer for two years but then I got
eventually a little bit frustrated and I
was wondering what to do next so I was
checking online courses and stuff and if
anything first I checked some Harvard
course about cooking about molecular
gastronomy and I spent like three months
doing that but I said to me okay I
cannot be cool because I'm sweating and
in the kitchen there's a lot of hot in
here so I couldn't cook so I try to
watching for something else and then I
find first some of course on udemy about
programming and CSS HTML and JavaScript
and I try that but then it was just a
tutorial you know building things that
are people built so it was kind of it
was great I can motivate it but it was
just a first level and then I discovered
free code camp and those algorithms and
it was basically a different dimension
for me because before I was just
creating stuff according to tutorials
but with the with algorithms I need to
really understand and at first I got
really frustrated because I think oh my
god is so difficult I cannot be
developer but then it really just would
be better and better and finally I got
really confident and really I started
learning to code during the weekends and
on the evenings and it eventually took
me seven months to switch from a lawyer
to develop purchase coding in
the weekends and nights so I'm really
grateful free coach came because it
really motivated me to see all the
people doing the same thing
although so why I decide for
contributing for record time by writing
articles because you know a free code
camp community helped me to became
developer and I also wanted to
contribute to it by by showing people
concepts that were difficult for me so I
try to like describe them in a way that
are more understandable for me and in a
way that I want them to be to see them
when I learned them because there were
no resources before
yeah and that's I think the part of my
story and maybe just the the main thing
what I decided to change switch the
careers was that as a lawyer I didn't
see the results of my work and as a as a
programmer I mean you might consume that
log and you see the result is it's so
motivating you just white coat and you
see the result I love this and this is
why I love programming Cheers tell us a
little about about what you're working
on out in Portugal Eduardo and and
you're leading the study group there
well I first knew free code camp in the
beginning of 2017 and I was a civil
engineering and I was not happy with my
career I wanted to reboot into into
programming and when I met free code
camp I met the right path
to start learning how to program I've
tried a lot of boot camps without effort
but with free code camp it was very very
easy to follow follow up and at the same
time that I was studying I started to
motivate people to study with me I
started at same time as wrong Eric and
together we started the study group in
our city and we impersonated also the
starting of the study group in Lisbon
the capital of Portugal
and we are doing that effort every week
even after we get got our jobs yeah I've
rebooted my career in five months
studying more or less ten hours per day
but it was math it was five months and I
got from civil engineering to a
front-end developer how many people
within your study group we've gotten
developer jobs do you think yeah
first me see let me tell you that we are
in the south of Portugal so it's a small
town like 50,000 inhabitants and in the
last year we got five five developers
ready to start working and they started
working so I think it's a nice person -
so basically one out of 10,000 people in
your town has gotten the developer job
thanks largely to your efforts and your
community outreach have a seat man you
lead the pre-cooking vienna group along
with Daniel Deutsch who who couldn't
make it
he's a student tell us a little bit
about the origins of freako camp Vienna
which I think you said is about three
years old now yeah it's like there's so
much to say but it basically started I
now have a developer job and I mainly
attribute that to freako camp which is
awesome and when I started as a student
shortly after there's this there was I
think it still is this is getting
started guide and you're getting courage
to check up your local group there was
no local group but there was a nice
guide saying if there is no local group
start a Facebook group but this is how
you do it so I did and then no one came
so I asked my wife to join I invited her
we were to then like this is probably at
least in the span of a couple of days
there was still no more people joining
so I got impatient so I think I texted
you on Gator or something I was like I
don't know if Quincy Larson will reply
to me but he replied and he was awesome
and I was asking can I start a meet-up
to come group because I knew meetups
from my city there's a quite a bit of
them
thinking that that's the way I could get
more people involved because I wanted to
meet other students right and then I did
that and you replied like yeah of course
sure just keep in mind it cost money and
stuff and I was like that's fine so
that's basically how it started in the
format that we have now we've been going
almost three years like this I think
November or December
well atheria thank you so much for
flying in from Greece you are a very
prominent person in the freako camp
community especially recently you've
been live-streaming a whole lot of
videos you've been creating videos on
things like angular it's it's incredibly
helpful tell us a little about how you
got into tech and how you started
deciding to record all this and share
all this knowledge and firstly I wanted
to learn for me and for myself but I
knew that eventually I wanted to find a
job and I wanted to be sure that
everything I know I can also like go to
another person and maybe teach them so I
said okay how can I do that so start
coding in my computer as always and then
I'm going to record this videos and if
they are good then I'm going to upload
them so basically that's how I started I
wanted to pass this knowledge to other
people and make sure that I also know
these things and is a prolific
contributor to freako camp I think I've
spent more time pairing with him than
pretty much anybody in the free cocaine
community
gosh let me let me just recount some of
the things you've worked on so you were
you were very heavily involved in the
JavaScript curriculum which pretty much
everybody who's watching this has
probably try it at some point you
created the challenge of matic which was
the tool to make it easier to contribute
challenges well tell us a little about
yourself
I'm based here I am currently kind of a
college student detergent my degree is
all work placement so I'm currently a
working man
year in kernel development actually
which was a complete payment from
JavaScript book yeah
well what are some things that aside
from kernel development and hopefully
eating back into freakin contribution
what are some areas of technology since
you're somebody who is you know at many
different places in the stack and has a
pretty good bird's-eye view on on how
things are moving what are some things
that really excite you about tech
information technology and the way
things are going in terms of new things
I guess there's a lot of scope for I
guess yeah like this is trying to in
love with the tire integration of
Technology and people I feel like
there's a lot of issues that are and not
serious enough that they need a solution
in the past but it becomes so easy to
solve that they will be a great example
is the the whole health technology kind
of revolution the way Evans get that
heart rate can't seem out and all the
kind of stuff there's been many cases of
people probably got their afib or atrial
fibrillation if you want the full
terrible thing and because of their
Smart Watch it's like there's an article
really really but an Apple watch alert
of the person to it and it's stuff like
that duck and you know makes huge
difference in the lives because they're
you know if you find achieve atrial
fibrillation need to get it sorted and
it's fine if you sort it and if you
don't you get lot yourself a lot of
trouble so there's all kinds of
applications of health technology
particularly that are not only really
exciting because they're curled but
they're also really exciting cuz they're
good they're doing a good thing in the
world Matt tell us a little bit about
your background and what you're doing
yeah so I'm I'm originally a music
teacher I studied music at University
talk guitar on piano for several years
and then which I still do actually just
a little bit in evenings and weekends
but I realized it wasn't the career for
me I wanted something which had a bit
more direction had more of a challenge
and I met a friend who I'd not seen in a
long time
he was studied music with me and he was
like
I'm a developer now how did how did that
happen and I knew that well I found a
lot of courses online and taught myself
and then a couple years later and that's
incredible and so I started just looking
around different resources and this was
so this was like three and a half years
ago four years ago so I was started with
a lot of course on Coursera EDX and
those kind of things which are really
good because they had he's kind of
deadlines so you had to get the core the
project in by a certain time then people
they reviewed them and then listened to
a lot podcasts and I think I feel it was
pretty JavaScript javi you were on and
you were talking about free code camp or
maybe was code newbie maybe both and and
I heard of a free code camp and started
trying that out and and realized
actually this is this is incredible free
platform and yeah just got really into
it and got quite disciplined about doing
it every day and then and then I heard
about these meetups were going on and
which at first I was not good enough to
go on to these about everyone's amazing
and it was quite intimidated by force
myself to go and then met people who
were very similar to me you know some
people who were above me some people who
weren't quite where I was and and found
that really and suddenly it was oh you
know maybe I can do this and and yeah
it's gone from there really
that's awesome so describe the
transition you're a musician and just
looking at the different steps you would
need to take and planning out your
progression as it became clearer and
clearer to you what you needed to do
I think yet to begin with it's it's fine
just to accept you're not gonna learn
everything in one go I think some people
think they maybe do it for a week and
think I feel like I don't know too much
yeah I'm never gonna have to do this is
so this just it can be overwhelming it's
good just again just do it initially
which I think I did just to try a few
things out and just just enjoy it really
not necessarily I mean I think I need to
do this and me become a developer as
soon as possible I think it's good too
time just to in yeah try to try some
things out and but then as you enjoy it
more hopefully and get a sense that it
is what you want to do trying to find
ways to keep yourself motivated in my
case it was initially doing these
courses which had deadlines at the end
of the week and then in the meetups
thinking okay there's another meetup in
two weeks I'd like to be able to show
something to someone by then you know
sometimes you feel like if you go along
and you've not done anything since last
time it's like you know it's a nice kind
of motivator having some peers around
you I think it's very easy to sort of
stay by yourself and get a bit isolated
but you know what we try and encourage
with the meetups is to get people to
come along and just you know talk to
people see where everyone else is don't
feel shy about it everyone's there to
help each other we're not about you know
criticising I mean might be constructive
criticism but yeah thanks again Matt
Timo is a prolific contributor I think I
was talking about you earlier when we
were going around in the circle but you
contributed an incredible amount and if
you look on the github repo and look
rank everything by commits you're way up
there what are some of the ways that
you've contributed to the free cooking
of community over the past year and a
half or so so when it started out as
almost exactly two years ago now I
started with making small changes mostly
to the curriculum small fixes to the
tests mostly so there was a test that
was missing correct solutions
it was allowing solutions that shouldn't
be allowed I try to fix those and that's
mostly what I started out doing and then
I found out about the free guide being
developed and actually had quite a bit
of time at the time that it was the next
development and I got involved and I
spent a lot of time on contributing to
the figure I came by to the path or not
the articles the concert but to the
platform the site around it well thanks
for all your articles so far Sam they've
been living great
and very well received by the community
yeah thank you very like the first
article I wrote I was I wrote it just
because I was in China and I hated the
Great Great Firewall of China and I sent
it to you and said can you have a look
and you said you loved it and actually
made me an author on the on the free
code camp medium ask on the medium
publication and that just gave me the
boost I needed every other school before
that like five ten maybe fifteen viewers
getting on the free code camp thing
boosted me and gave me the confidence to
write more and that was really big for
me what would be your advice to those
people who already have kind of a
traditional engineering training but are
interested in pivoting into software
development if you're interested in
pivoting into software at all give it a
try stuff like free code camp and
there's hundreds of other free resources
out there they're all absolutely
brilliant I learn most of the stuff I
know now through free code camp it's
free
it has step-by-step tutorials and give
you really good feedback as you're
progressing through and the worst that
happens is you try it out you do two or
three months and you find that you don't
enjoy it that much thanks again for
coming up man it's great great to
finally meet you Richard I'm so thrilled
we've talked so many times we've been in
touch Richard is in charge of free
cooking leads free code camp Oslo and
the free cooking of Instagram which has
I don't know ten thousand dish yeah and
it's it's great photos of freako camp
events and just beautiful workstations
and code setups and things like that all
the good stuff
yeah what are your goals so you really
took charge on the Instagram and I mean
you owned it for you were already very
prolific on Instagram you had a lot of
your own photos you had a ton of
followers yourself and you really took
the freaking of Instagram which was
largely just chilling there cuz I think
I was the only person who had access to
the time and and and now it's it's quite
vibrant and there's a lot of beautiful
photos on there can you describe that
process of thinking like hey maybe I
could help out with this and and how you
went about it yes I think it took you
from about 3000 at the time are you
saying it was like underutilized I think
the thing I think you were very very
very good on Twitter and things like
that that stuff was doing it what I was
doing on my own Instagram was just
pictures of my code stuff I'm working on
and things like that so we had the
conversation about doing some stuff with
a free coke and pointing to it have a
lot more of the communiques stuff in
there as well trying to be real glowed
over people's pictures we gram them or
they color so that's kind of what we try
to do get the community thing more in
there
and just try and try and build that up
and have a bit more of a community
little bit more so other people could
get involved in that as well so that was
the plan
yeah yeah and early on you you made a
clear point that people could basically
add mention free coke camper hashtag
free coke amp on Instagram and we get
basically signal boost their photos and
and of course credit them and everything
our people still doing that pretty
regularly we need them to do it more do
it more especially to do with if there's
meetups going on that stuff's great so
if we got me and you got picture of all
the groups and stuff like that we load
that stuff so I could send those stuff
yeah I'm constantly going in there
checking the hashtags or if you've been
tagging as in them directly as well
trying to find the good stuff out there
and posting it on there so if if people
send me the good stuff then it means I
don't have to do anything so I said what
we want to do for everything you're
doing Richard
and Allah has contributed extensively to
freako camp through the free cooking of
guide and also publishing articles on
medium tell us a little bit about
yourself and how you discovered freako
camp and decided to contribute to it
okay at the moment I'm a student
actually just started like last week
University my journey with frequent camp
started when I moved from like too sharp
to JavaScript because I needed to learn
no GS for like a server application and
I basically discovered for attempt to
learn JavaScript then I started like
reading the articles on the medium
publication and when I decided that I
wanted to also write articles it just
felt natural to go to publish the
articles on the media publication and
then from there like the involvement
with the community just like grew
gradually how old are you 18
oh wow you're getting really into really
deep into technology pretty young and
that's that's excellent yeah I actually
like started my first experiences with
coding like at 12
the story goes basically oh I like games
why not make one and then like I just
started with those software that lets
you just create the game with
drag-and-drop stuff and then you say oh
I want what these like cool feature I
will learn some scripting and then or
programming super cool I will own this
alright Cheers
so Matt's over here we're gonna take a
big group photo and then we're gonna
gracefully leave thank you so much for
tuning in for the stream we got to talk
to a lot of exciting people doing
exciting work both within the free
cocaine community and just working as
developers so I hope you all have a
beautiful evening
you